Je suis une
arme, je ne choisis pas où je vais faire la
guerre, il y a
un travail, je ne suis plus dans l'
entreprise, je cible deux
assassins l'un pour l'autre, un
contrat potentiel, le double de vos honoraires habituels, c'est un
travail, je le prends pour l'
autre.  c'est
personnel, je veux
maintenant deux R, tu veux dire moi, Miss, elle
deviendra alliée, la meilleure façon pour nous de l'avoir
est si vous travaillez ensemble, juste ce dont j'ai
besoin et sur le V,
le sale inter B ne peut pas me piéger,
je veux  l'homme qui K mon frère et pourquoi
le gars lion veut
suffisamment un partenaire pour la mort, il faut
que les gens choisissent leur mort quand ils
choisissent comment ils
quittent John
Clam Scott Aton les jeux d'assassinat,
vous réagissez de manière excessive si j'ai
réagi de manière excessive, ce sera
[Musique]
mort